pour cette question encore une fois
d'argent magique voilà ça me fait un peu
penser à casa del papel où effectivement
on voit la machine à imprimer on se dit
que c'est très facile et qu'on peut le
faire
l'argent il n'y a pas de côté magique
dans la monnaie elles ne sont pas du
ciel bien évidemment on peut dire que ça
peut être une avance sur quelque chose
qui arrivera après mais voilà c'est de
toute façon c'est un impact sur
l'économie la monnaie a toujours eu un
impact sur l'économie depuis tous les
temps il ya des médias des monarques qui
ont effectivement essayé aussi de ne pas
rembourser ou d'avoir des moyens
détournés pour ne pas rembourser comme
lorsqu'il j'utilisais des deux du cuivre
plutôt que de l'or pour pouvoir diminuer
la valeur de la monnaie en réalité mais
ça se finisse et ça finissait souvent en
catastrophe
le problème de la dette publique c'est
de savoir ce qu'on en fait et voilà donc
si la dette publique en plus non
seulement elle augmente mais elle n'est
pas productive et bien ça devient un
problème donc donc voilà donc pour le
moment qu après on est décidés à voir
une dette publique parce
qu'effectivement on est face à une
situation inédite où l'état du a ordonné
à des entreprises d'arrêter son activité
et bien cette dette elle est très liée à
un contexte et si ce contexte s'améliore
il n'y a pas de raison pour que l'état
ne puisse pas rembourser
et après on peut avoir envie de financer
de la finance verte
c'est un autre débat c'est un débat sur
la façon dont on alloue le budget de
l'état et là on consacre ne l'est pas on
décide de constater des part importante
du budget d'état mais en aucun cas ça on
a n'obtiendra quelque chose de mieux
avec avec un côté il n'ya pas de côté
magique à la monnaie
[Musique]